human activities from pollution to
overpopulation are driving up the
earth's temperature and fundamentally
changing the world around us the main
cause is a phenomenon known as the
greenhouse effect gases in the
atmosphere such as water vapor carbon
dioxide methane nitrous oxide and
chlorofluorocarbons let the sun's light
in but keep some of the heat from
escaping like the glass walls of a
greenhouse the more greenhouse gases in
the atmosphere the more heat gets
trapped strengthening the greenhouse
effect and increasing the earth's
temperature human activities like the
burning of fossil fuels have increased
the amount of co2 in the atmosphere by
more than a third since the Industrial
Revolution the rapid increase in
greenhouse gases in the atmosphere has
warmed the planet at an alarming rate
while Earth's climate has fluctuated in
the past atmospheric carbon dioxide
hasn't reached today's levels in
hundreds of thousands of years climate
change has consequences for our oceans
our weather our food sources and our
health ice sheets such as Greenland and
Antarctica are melting the extra water
that was once held in glaciers causes
sea levels to rise and spills out of the
oceans flooding coastal regions warmer
temperatures also make weather more
extreme this means not only more intense
major storms floods and heavy snowfall
but also longer and more frequent
droughts these changes in weather pose
challenges
growing crops becomes more difficult the
areas where plants and animals can live
shift and water supplies are diminished
in addition to creating new agricultural
challenges climate change can directly
affect people's physical health in urban
areas the warmer atmosphere creates an
environment that traps and increases the
amount of smog this is because smog
contains ozone particles which increase
rapidly at higher temperatures exposure
to higher levels of smog can cause
health problems such as asthma heart
disease and lung cancer while the rapid
rate of climate change is caused by
humans humans are also the ones who can
combat it if we work to replace fossil
fuels with renewable energy sources like
solar and wind which don't produce
greenhouse gas emissions we might still
be able to prevent some of the worst
effects of climate change
[Music]
you